good evening and emergency government
meeting is taking place tonight to
discuss progress on what's being called
the biggest cyberattack of its kind NHS
computer systems and machines around the
world are crippled on Friday after an
attack of malicious software the e use
law enforcement body has called unique
companies including this an and Hitachi
were also affected by the attack raising
questions about the cybersecurity of
businesses and their customers well
since what happened on Friday
47 NHS Trust in England were initially
affected by the cyber attack and 13 NHS
organisations in Scotland experienced
disruption around the world Europol has
said that more than 200,000 machines
were affected in 150 countries in
Friday's attack Rob Holmes is vice
president of products at Proofpoint a
cyber security company whose researcher
helped bring the halt to last week's
attack so Rob you been working solidly
over the weekend what's the current
state of affairs the current state of
affairs is that we have put out the fire
we believe then it's a matter of
containing that to make sure there
aren't any secondary attacks we think
we're in pretty good shape we will not
be complacent about that but then we
will look at the whys and the wherefores
and try and prevent this happening in
future now one of your researchers was
responsible for discovering this kill
switch that stopped the infection
spreading further but is there a danger
that another version of this malware
without a kill switch is out there
somewhere and that could wreak havoc in
the future there's not just a danger
that that is clear and present in its
danger so we have already seen variants
of this without kill switch and
fortunately the variant that we've seen
the ransomware did not actually execute
properly which is the silver lining of
this but we feel that it's only a matter
of time before the more professional and
skilled cyber criminals will develop a
variant that will detonate and that will
presumably have the greater longevity
and do more damage well one hopes that
by that stage the patches have been
installed in the relevant vulnerable
operating systems such that actually the
fact that this propagates so wildly
across their network is moot because
actually it'll just remain on the
individual computer and people have
their backups in place for quick restore
so you mentioned the patches I mean
clearly the the sister
the operating system that seems to have
been a fault here is Microsoft XP I mean
a business's fault for continuing with
this software I mean Microsoft offerings
stopped offering support for this quite
a while ago didn't they they did indeed
yes years ago I would say I would first
of all actually give credit to Microsoft
for the fact that they actually did
something quite exceptional over the
weekend is the HD issue patches for
unsupported versions indeed including
Windows XP so I would actually give them
credit at this point in time it becomes
a question of economics for how long do
you continue to support previous
versions of software therein lies the
balance of the argument so Microsoft
have actually behave quite altruistic
aliy over the week in my opinion
definitely right so though presumably
they make more money in the longer term
if people upgrade from XP to their
current they are an important entity in
the world of Internet services and
business services so what happens and if
I'm a business and I'm I'm hit by
another I break of this or I mean what
do you actually do I mean there was I
mean certainly here at Sky News we're
all told to reboot our systems this
morning for example yes so I mean the
first thing if you are if you are
targeted with ransomware and you boot
your computer and you see the dreaded
screen asking for money do not pay that
ransom that's the first thing the second
thing is actually I would encourage you
not to imagine you reboot go and see
somebody in your IT security team
because there are different strains of
ransomware that will actually play on
the fact that you reboot and in fact
deeper into the operating system right I
should point out here Sky News wasn't
hit by this but so we so we shouldn't
actually reboot yeah I would say the
first port of call is to go to see your
IT security team and I hope is that
actually this has been a real wake-up
call for businesses that they have now a
greater mantra about updating patches
and that this is a hopefully a shot
across the bow now Jeremy Hunt the
health secretary came on the airwaves
today for the first time over the since
this all started and basically accused
labour of politicizing the event but is
there a case for actually saying the
government was at fault for not
equipping the NHS to see off this kind
of attack a very difficult to say and
I'll leave the politics of the
politicians what I will say is that this
is a business challenge businesses are
faced with risk
from morning until night the question is
is that risk sufficiently above your
tolerance for risk that you should do
something about it my hope is that this
illustrates that cybercrime is something
that businesses should take very
seriously and invest in accordingly the